marleix écoute plutôt ton père si ces
gamines t'embrouille tu te mérite pas en
mode ghetto si cette affiche qui leur
peine waouh tu vous savez qui suit
gilbert
alex frei que tu l'avais lourdes et à ce
compte là fallait rester marié tu
l'avais moins dans les tacles et fernand
mariage dont la plus longue relation
c'est autant par week est qu'elle est la
seule chose au monde qui soit
essentielle pour la famille entière moi
as tu parlé avec marianne dit jamais
joué les parents comptait pas là c'est
juste un gentil garçon qui apprécie la
compagnie de philo des rasoirs à mourir
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
je me suis un peu maquillée menace la
tête encore pire qu'à halloween de type
ans marlon et toi où il n'avait jamais
mais le sexe ça en plus dire que ça
marchait bien entre nous c'est clair
c'est vrai goût
je peux faire tout ce que je veux avec
les nanas m'éclater avec ashley des
gosses
j'ai une vie des halles grand moi je
viens tu cherchais à cholet pour fou je
sais que c'est bizarre de dire ça son ex
d'un impossible que tu puisses mon père
pour former famille monsieur madame wang
votre fils marley a dit certaines choses
à la cafétéria cet après midi très
politiquement incorrect tu veux te
frites et tu sais pas qui je suis
[Musique]